hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host john carroll
welcome to 2022 a whole new year i hope
you're all excited
for the new year it's getting harder and
harder to say you know very excited
about the new year when previous years
have been a bit of a downer with the
pandemic and other things but still
hoping things get better in this year
we're going to start the new year with a
big one the question of what is real
really we have talked about this
question before but
interestingly it's a question that
physicists don't like to talk about you
would think that physicists who care
about the structure and reality of the
physical world would care a lot about
what is real and what is not but they're
much more operational they're much more
down to earth than that most physicists
they want to know what they're going to
see in their experiments and you know at
the boundaries when it comes to like
virtual particles or the multiverse or
something like that there are some
things they're not sure whether should
qualify as real or not and they don't
like to talk about that it sort of gets
them all discomforted whereas
philosophers love to talk about what is
real so that's what we're going to do
today with philosopher jody azuni and
jody has a relatively extremist point of
view on these questions he is what is
called a nominalist
so nominalism goes back i think to
william of ockham of occam's razor fame
and nominalism is the idea that abstract
objects don't exist so it's in contrast
with something like platonism platonism
about math for example would say that
mathematical structures and ideas exist
they're real in some sense
as previous podcast guest justin clark
doane said that doesn't mean that
they're out there somewhere there's not
uh what did he what did he call it
plutonium or something like that some
place where you find perfect triangles
etc but there's a reality to these
mathematical structures for example
if it weren't true why is it so useful
to use math when discussing the real
world so a lot of mathematicians are
platonists they think that mathematical
structures have some reality to them
nominalism is a relatively minority
position uh at least among philosophers
of math so jody izuni is here to
give you the apologia for nominalism so
here's why this is an interesting
question you might say something like
look if you don't believe numbers exist
then you don't believe prime numbers
exist so how could you say something
like
there are prime numbers between 10 and
20 if you don't think there are any
prime numbers at all just talking about
math it would seem so the argument goes
implies or takes for granted the
existence of these actual things and so
what jody's going to say is something
like i'll let him put it into his own
words but it's something like look
sherlock holmes doesn't exist he was not
a real person named sherlock holmes but
we constantly talk about sherlock holmes
as as jody will say we say that sherlock
holmes is smarter than mickey mouse
we're comparing the relative smartness
of two things that don't exist so it is
possible to talk about things that don't
exist in a useful way now math is
trickier than that
i myself am
somewhat on the nominalist side i'm
sympathetic to it but my understanding
of the foundations of mathematics and
the philosophy of mathematics is not
nearly good enough for me to be very
convinced in my own point of view that's
why i wanted to talk to one of the
experts here and
we'll get into why it matters right i
mean who cares what exists and not as
long as we can make predictions for what
we're actually going to experience well
i think it does matter and i think that
our goal should be more
than to just know what will happen next
in the world our goal should be some
understanding of what the world is and
how it behaves and that involves what
parts of the world are real and what
parts are kind of stories that we want
to tell
along the way that are helpful or
entertaining to us but are not latching
on to any reality that is actually out
there so even though i have an opinion
here i'm still pretty open-minded about
it i want to explore this and i think
this podcast is a very good way of
getting there also because jody's very
good at words he is a published poet
quite successfully uh likes talking
likes writing he expresses himself in a
very entertaining and also extremely
clear way so this is going to be a good
way to start the new year let's go
[Music]
jody azuni welcome to the mod k podcast
glad to be here
let's talk about what is real not not
don't tell me yet what is real but let's
talk about the question what is real
because it's interesting that as a
physicist i talk to my friends who are
physicists
they don't care what is real like they
get they get very nervous when you start
asking questions about that they think
you're being too philosophical which
which is fascinating to me because if
anyone should care what's real i think
as a physicist so i mean maybe give the
sales pitch for why we should care about
what is real and what is not real
well i mean
my pitch for that because as you can
gather there are certainly philosophers
who say
this is not an interesting question or
this is a bogus question or this is a
fake question
and for me it's not a fake question
because of of course in the background
what i think
when you're asking if something is real
what you're really asking
and i think
you know we have a picture
of
things that are kind of
and i'm going to speak very roughly yeah
things that are kind of independent of
us
and other things that aren't independent
of us
okay
so my my go-to example is always
sherlock holmes
you know now there's a sense in which
the concept and the ideas and the
stories and the material about sherlock
holmes is independent of of me anyway
right i i can get sherlock holmes wrong
in certain respects
and people do and you might uncover a
notebook of um doyle's in which you find
out okay here's what was really going on
with sherlock holmes and then you can
see the text is
real weirdly hermeneutical and there's
things you know that can happen
nevertheless it's not independent of
sherlock of doyle
right you know doyle you know um
pen and hand said i want to go this way
i want to go that way blah blah blah
you don't get to do that with things
that are real
okay
um
even the things that are real that you
can affect for example
um aspects and states to some extent of
your own brain
you can't do it by just
pen in hand let me change that you know
yeah you got to put
there's a process and to me
i call that sometimes mind and language
independent okay
and i say that's a criterion for what's
real
um there's a little bit of complexity
here but that's roughly the idea
why do we care
because we want to separate what we're
making up from what we're not
now there are philosophers um
almost all um major philosophers up
until say
oh the 1980s and i'm thinking of people
like putnam like quine you know thought
you can't
drive a wedge between these things you
can't separate you know what you're
making up and what you're not what
you're projecting onto the world
and what's really there
i actually think that's wrong i don't
think it's easy
okay
um a few books have been written
you know and that's why i end up writing
a lot of books i mean it's not just to
make sure that i have a job
it's it's because
um
it's kind of complicated so just take
what our senses present to us what we
see
um a lot of what we see
indicates what's really out there but a
lot of what we see is a projection
of our biology of our culture
all mixed up
so it's it's not an easy thing to do but
i think it's a real distinction and we
care about it because when we get down
to you know how is the world working how
are things
happening you know how's
we want it's the real stuff that's
telling us that's the motor
so that's why we care i think that makes
sense but i mean let's uh
make let people in on all the various
ways in which it's a complicated
question right before getting to what
the right answers are uh we can bring up
some edge cases like most of us agree
that sherlock holmes is not real
although even there
conan doyle wrote about him so there's a
sense in which he's real but you know
he's a fictional character okay but what
about things like
ultimately i want to get to like physics
and math but what about things like a
country or a family do those perfect
examples okay
perfect examples um
look for the time being let's say that
pretty much our description of human
beings is real
you know what a human being and that's
complicated too because our picture of a
human being is a very complex notion
that involves oh norms of various sorts
and other things as well as just the
sheer physical presence of a bunch of
cells coordinated for a while right but
but what's going on is that let's just
go with that for the moment
what's a country well it's really quite
subtle there are things that are real
in a country or constituting a country
and there are things that aren't
so with something like a country you've
got to analyze it
you don't simply
you know go a certain way now look
something important is kicking in here
with the words yeah okay
when we start talking about banks
countries uh borders
right
we human beings
i i don't this doesn't happen in other
species as far as i know but human
beings
automatically think
a thing yeah a thing with properties
you know and and and they go even
further i mean here you read the
economist for example right i read it
and the economist you know tries to be
pretty rigorous in its way
nevertheless you hear things you read
things all the time like
china is not happy
with
the u.s policy regarding such and such
okay and i i look at that and i say okay
you know that's
there are two things going on one of
them is how else are they supposed to
convey a certain aspect of chinese
policy we don't have a different way of
doing it right
second of all does it really follow that
there's this thing china
that's you know has attitudes
no
well maybe we're it's it's short-term
hand for the individuals in china that
are ruling the place
that's not so straightforward
right okay so again it's a it's a
subtlety
but in point of fact the borderline
cases invariably turn out to be like
this
they're not straightforward cases of
something that exists
they are
a complex blend of
stuff that does exist
coupled with
our ways of packaging and bundling how
we think about it so you said something
i think that makes perfect sense to me
uh about our linguistic way of
grasping these ideas like we have a way
of talking about tables and chairs let's
for the moment say the tables and chairs
are real and we have a way of talking
about them you know moving them they
have an impact they have causal powers
etc and it just is natural for us to
then use the same kind of linguistic
strategies when we talk about more
abstract things like countries and
families but right
can i stop you just for a second
you're absolutely right it's very
natural for us
but don't think it's natural in some
broader sense
it's just it this is an aspect of how
the human mind works
all human minds they go yeah i talk
about tables and chairs this way i talk
about people this way i talk about
countries this way i talk about clouds
this way
yeah
very natural yeah or or fictional
characters for that matter right or
fictional characters or mathematical
objects
as we will get to in brain splitting
detail i'm sure so okay but then
so where do you personally come down on
the countries aspect before we get into
details about how we draw the line
are countries real do they exist in your
ontology
yeah but
what what they're composed of elements
of them for sure okay okay same thing
for institutions like oh i don't know
microsoft
and again
we implicitly do this when we really
start to analyze these things and not
just speak vaguely at a certain distance
about ooh microsoft has this attitude or
is doing this we start to look at the
parts that are real
and and ask what's going on with them oh
here's a policy that the ceo is pushing
here's something that was going on there
was a dispute about this here are some
regulations that are in place
those end up helping us to predict how
the
so-called institution is going to move
through space and time in certain
respects
that's that's how i picture it
so you know at the end of the day if
someone says to me
are you committed to the existence of
microsoft i'm going to say
no
but that doesn't mean i think it's like
sherlock holmes
donating money to help people can be a
wonderful and selfless act but how can
you feel confident that your donations
are improving or saving lives
effectively one of the best ways is to
visit givewell.org there you'll get a
short vetted list of the best charities
they've found at saving or improving
lives per dollar give wellspans over 20
000 hours each year researching
charitable organizations and only
recommends a few of the highest impact
evidence-backed charities they've found
for example there are charities that do
cash transfers for extreme poverty
giving money directly to people and many
high-quality studies show that
recipients use money to buy goods that
improve their lives over 50 000 donors
have used givewell to donate more than
750 million dollars rigorous evidence
suggests that these donations will save
tens of thousands of lives and improve
the lives of millions more and the best
part is givewell is free they publish
their recommendations on their site no
sign up required so go to givewell.org
to read more about their research or
donate to any of their recommended
charities that's givewell.org and enter
mindscape at checkout so they know we
sent you
well that's why it's tricky so one
question is are there different senses
of the word exist is it possible to have
like different
levels of existence or something like
that i mean
one one one attitude might be
the word microsoft or even sentences
like microsoft wants to do the following
thing these are really useful sentences
these convey a lot of information they
seem to latch on to something real about
the world and therefore we should
attribute reality to what they're
referring to
okay so again um
this is complicated the first thing to
point out is uh on my view not every
philosopher agrees with this on my view
the question about
the word exist or the phrase there is
or the word real
uh do they have different senses
like are there different senses of there
is are there different senses of exist
are these three words different from one
another in what they mean
these are purely linguistic questions
these are not philosophical questions
okay these are questions to be answered
by the lexical semanticist
in my view
uh the answer to the question for
example does exist have different
meanings
is no
okay and i claim there are kind of
humdrum linguistic tests for that
okay
now the other so that's one thing so i'm
just going gonna say that about that bit
now here's the other thing you say look
you can make certain kinds of statements
that are really informative here's an
informative statement it's either true
or false i don't know which it is
because i've never done a
a head count as it were
there are as many greek
goddesses as greek gods okay now that's
either true or false
okay i don't know which it is
but
if you ask well what's making it true or
false what's not making it true or false
is some kind of correspondence right
sure okay if i say there are three
chairs in my bedroom
that statement turns out i'm looking
around that statement turns out to be
false
and it's a correspondence question right
you know there's a word chair it refers
to chairs how many chairs are in here
none okay so it's false
but there is many greek gods as
goddesses you don't go around looking at
the greek gods and goddesses to figure
out how many there are
so
yes the statement is informative and it
corresponds
in a broad way to a true you know it's a
truth that corresponds to a way that the
world is but
not because the words in it refer to
specific things that exist that are
certain ways sure okay so i i think i
get that but there is
there's a multi-layered distinction here
that i want to get right on so
in the case of the greek gods we could
if there were some definitive canonical
list answer that question by looking at
the list and what you're saying is we're
not looking at the gods and goddesses to
do that we're looking at someone's list
that someone made up and said that's
right and the list is a cultural product
uh diffused from yeah yeah exactly that
makes perfect when it comes yeah then
but i think that's different to me than
the microsoft question because i i'm
when i'm saying that you know microsoft
is acting aggressively that tells me
something about the world not just about
someone's figments of their imagination
correct and that's because different
kinds of sentences that don't correspond
directly to the world
their relationship to the world differs
in different cases okay in the case of
the
fictions
it really just refers to a
a kind of literary slash movie practice
let's say
uh in the case of
microsoft
it's gonna correspond to something a bit
more complicated namely
the
the actions and uh decisions and
other facts and legal papers
that are kicking around that we regard
as part of microsoft in some broad sense
of part
okay
okay
again
it doesn't turn on the object microsoft
being aggressive
it turns on a series of actions carried
out by individuals who in various ways
are connected to microsoft as we
understand it okay so i'm just gonna uh
you know actually i should say that i'm
broadly sympathetic to your most of your
points of view here but it's my job of
course as the as the host to uh pretend
to be skeptical at the appropriate times
so
i think i buy that i think i get that
that you know we're we're talking about
microsoft in a way that conveys useful
information about the world but really
it's because it conveys useful
information about the real things that
make up what we think of as microsoft
but then wouldn't the same kind of logic
say the tables and chairs don't exist
all that exists is the atoms or the
particles that make them up
um
yeah that would follow if you
decided that here's a principle of what
exists you know go for the smallest bits
that make it up
and i'm gonna say no that's not how it
works
um
one of the reasons i'm gonna say no
that's not quite how it works is because
um there's nothing wrong with saying
that you've got a thing in front of you
if the bits are operating in a certain
way with respect to each other
and going on now you're gonna ask me and
you should okay what's the principal
difference here between
um a human being made up of a lot of
bits and uh microsoft being made up of a
lot of bits now one of the things that's
gonna go on is that a lot of what's
going on with microsoft doesn't involve
little bits that are really in microsoft
okay
you don't have microsoft isn't in that
sense a physical object
it's kind of a stipulated object
uh and you'd make the same mistake with
a bank if you said well we're well you
know where's the bank physically
and then you say okay well it's all
these people and it's these uh locations
in um
you know physical space you know the
bank the bank offices and then you find
out that hsbc for example is kind of or
there are other banks now that are
entirely online
and then you go okay so where are they
located uh
and you start to realize it's really not
the location that's doing the work here
sure
good it's a stipulated
[Music]
we're constituting it out of these
things
so what i want to say is is that what
kind of works in the case of a person
where you can actually see
well you don't see but you know you're
thinking of the person as literally
constituted of
little bits
that are operating causally in a way and
that the causation
actually sums up to in certain respects
the causation that
the person manifests i'm moving my hand
and now the story you're going to tell
ultimately is going to be an anatomical
slash molecular slash story about forces
that's not the kind of story you can
tell about microsoft okay i think i
think i actually get it now let me let
me try to phrase it back and you can
tell me whether i've gotten it um as you
said from the beginning we should attach
reality or existence to things that
exist independent of our minds in some
sense and
if there were no human beings around
there would still be a fact of the
matter about whether the coffee cup is
sitting on the table but if there were
no human beings around there's no facts
of the matter about what microsoft is
doing because it's entirely something
that exists in human minds is that
that's right although there may still be
a fact of a lot of the things right that
were moving around that we treated as
part of microsoft right so if you treat
a country as geographically located that
geographical spread is real even if
there's no person
okay no people right but nevertheless
making it a country and by the way of
course geographical spread is hardly all
there is to making a country a country
that's important right
uh
that wouldn't be there although these
other things would be there so if you
treat london for example now i'm kind of
borrowing an example that i've read
dozens of times from chomsky and quoted
because i love it
you know he talks about london and he
says oh london is so polluted and dirty
etc that it should be moved upstream 500
miles of the dam and reef
right he talks a certain way and what
you're seeing is a cross
conflict almost of
different ways that we treat london as
existing yeah as a thing
and some those facts could all be there
without a london without people i mean
imagine it could still be polluted i
mean pollution is us but
imagine it's still you know there's
still the geographic location imagine
you know etc you see what i'm saying
yeah i do okay and i think and and just
to be clear because some people
might have gotten the wrong idea you're
not attaching reality to any special
features of spatiotemporal location
that's that's i'm not committing myself
to that yeah
and i'm just being illustrative sure
exactly and then what about i guess the
obvious next question there is what
about things that are not nouns
are you know properties and relations
can do they have existence uh
i presume the answer is yes if they
exist independent of our minds
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna describe
myself as having gone through two phases
okay for a very long time up until uh
some point in 2017
i was what you might call a hobsean
nominalist
after thomas hopps and basically the
idea was there are objects okay they're
careening around
there is also the way objects are but
those aren't things those don't exist
objects just are certain ways
and we're talking about properties and
relations we're really just talking
about objects are in certain ways
okay
my current view is
weird enough and complicated enough that
i almost don't want to describe it
but it's something like
look there really aren't objects or
properties because in order to get your
idea of an object you have to kind of
put a border around it in space and time
and you got to circumvent it uh
circumscribe it in other ways as well
modally as philosophers say
and i think all of that's arbitrary
the in the sense of it's not in the
world right you know like if you ask
yourself are these borders in the world
are they
independent of it
no there isn't anything like that
so my current view is that
the way reality is is it's a kind of of
all right i'm gonna go horribly
metaphorical i'm so sorry um um you know
it's a kind of fabric that's spread out
okay uh
and i call it's a feature fabric so
there are these features they're not
properties they're not objects
you know it's just
a spread of features i think that's all
i want to say about that because you
know otherwise
you're not you're going to start
sounding zen-like or something mystical
weird scary
i have a book on this but and i hope the
book you know
kind of conveys what i have in mind but
this is a tough one i know for our
purposes we might as well just leave me
with the hobby and nominalism because
that makes sense that's clear to people
i'm sure well except except that you
know now you're i can't let it go
because you're bumping right up against
literally the research i'm doing right
now in quantum mechanics i just had a
paper out
earlier this year saying the reality is
is just a vector in hilbert space
and what we do is we ask questions about
the possible emergent patterns we can
find in that single
vector in some hugely high dimensional
vector space and so following someone
like dan dennett your colleague right at
tufts and his idea of real patterns if
there are ways of of describing the
world even if they're just approximate
at some higher level of abstraction they
should still count as real otherwise
you're not going to be able to hold on
to tables and chairs right yeah now
the thing i want to say i have not yet
officially written about quantum
mechanics and this kind of issue
um i intend to all of this
turns on my living long enough and who
knows
so much turns on that you know
but my own view is is the emergent
patterns that you described that's real
yeah okay the hilbert vector space yep
that's a mathematical formalism
okay now
the reason i think this in a nutshell
is because there's a strong tendency we
have to think
if i get a characterization of something
and that characterization is empirically
on the money
that's evidence that everything that
characterization talks about
mathematically and otherwise exists
i'm going to reject that yeah
i'm going to say what exists is in a
certain sense
what we get and now this is my own kind
of language
epistemic access to thick epistemic
access to we need instrumental access we
need
manipulation access things like that so
i'm happy
with the kind of middle level
description of objects they're jumping
around you know or they're shifting or
they're a wave pattern
i like all that and i say yeah that is
real
but the mathematical formalism that
we're in that we use to enable us to
describe it even to unbelievably good
accuracy
i'm not going to claim that's real i
think that's fine but i i'm always
sloppy because i am a physicist not a
philosopher and when i say that reality
is a vector in hilbert's face what i
mean is reality is reality it's suey
generous but it is represented
accurately by a very very very simple
mathematical structure that doesn't a
priori have any sub-pieces then we ask
afterward is it possible to
describe it in terms of sub-pieces that
have some you know real heft to them and
finally the answer is yes etc so i don't
think i'm that far away but uh
but then just to be super clear that i'm
on the right page what about something
like the velocity of an object if the
object exists does its velocity exist or
is that a mathematical abstraction we
use to talk about it
it may it may prove to be a mathematical
abstraction
uh it may not i mean it again it depends
on
on
the nature of the relations we're
looking at how we get access to
them um how
what kind of role the mathematical
formalism is playing in
kind of constituting them
okay so velocity in particular right
seems to be something that we almost
stipulate as opposed to accelerations
yeah right
and that is an argument for saying well
you know velocity isn't real
okay but acceleration is
right okay and this
i i kind of do the same thing in a in a
different way when it comes to space
time
so for example in the newtonian context
let's assume that was right i would say
something like no space time isn't real
okay
uh it is a way of describing way ways
that objects are it's a relational kind
of thing not a substance
it's not substantial but more
importantly we don't have to be
committed to it right
okay so the
substance where the substantial
relational distinction isn't quite
mapping on to the distinction i've got
in mind it kind of
it's a cousin
okay
on the other hand when you end up with a
space time playing a substantial
physical role containing energy etc etc
you may or may not be
dealing with something you should be
committed to and again it's going to
turn on the details
of how you get access to it and
what what role the mathematical
formalism is playing etc so
it seems like a disadvantage of this
view is that something as basic as the
velocity of a car with respect to the
road beneath it
is something which we don't know whether
it's real at the present moment it's to
depend on future developments in physics
and philosophy
well that i think
um
if somebody was hoping
you know i want a nice crisp
straightforward description of what's
real that doesn't give any hostages to
future science or future thinking
philosophical thinking i would say yeah
you're out of luck come to the wrong
place yeah you've come to the wrong
place and i think it was an unreasonable
demand okay okay
um i think the concept of what exists is
not that
uh
esoteric as i that's how we began the
interview
but that doesn't mean that the result of
discovering what falls under it
is going to be straightforward and i
mean this shows up
straight easily in lots of ways i mean
we're worrying about
the subtlety of certain concepts but i
mean it comes up
is bigfoot real or not that's an
empirical question and i think the
answer is no so you i suspect
but we have better we have other
examples that are are more subtle
right that it's not obvious and yeah
we're beholden to the science
okay uh to tell us the answer and that's
as it should be
i mean sure if someone says uh is are
weakly interacting massive particles as
the dark matter are they real
uh yeah science hasn't told us yet
whether they're real that seems
different than velocity to me
i i'd like to think that's because
you've lived with it with velocity so
long okay i mean i want i i'm gonna
switch to a mathematical example which i
think is the same thing
um as it turns out so
the notion of a group you're familiar
with that i am but maybe the folks in
the audience aren't so okay it's a
mathematical object of a certain sort um
a very broad class of mathematical
objects that obey certain properties you
can do simple arithmetic with them right
that's basically the characterization of
a group you know you can do
multiplication not necessarily
multiplication and addition that would
be a ring
but multiplication
or addition however you want to think
about it now our normal notion uh
intuitive notion of a group is it's it's
a class of objects
and i said that to begin with all
different kinds of groups all with
different kinds of structure
our intuitive picture of the natural
numbers 0 1 2 3 4 5
going on forever and no more
we have a different intuitive picture of
that our intuitive picture of that is
that's one kind of thing that's one
thing the numbers the numbers yeah
turns out
there are lots of things that can fit
that structure
okay
that was discovered along with what's
called you know non-standard models
okay you characterize
the numbers in piano arithmetic and then
you discover there are lots of things
that fit that model
and it's not clear we can get the one
we're really thinking of which is what i
just said zero one two three and no more
right because characterizing the and no
more is non-trivial
uh uh
okay
um
so
we but we have a different picture and
the picture is intuitive that you know
well then we have this intended model
when we're talking about the numbers
whereas we don't have an intended models
when we're talking about groups i
actually don't think there's a real
distinction here
so it's the same thing i think yeah the
lots of different kinds of piano numbers
right okay yeah
i'm actually on board with that but yeah
my friends are not always so i mean
maybe this is worth
noting for the listeners that uh is it
fair to describe your view as extreme
within the world of philosophers
um
again that's something you have to ask
other philosophers but i believe the
answer is yes
i just gave a little talk at a workshop
the day before yesterday where i talked
a little bit about how
a certain very natural model of
mathematical proof that arose among the
ancient greeks
was misleading
because it became our notion of
justification as well
and then we had a very narrow picture of
how we justified that really didn't
handle all sorts of other ways that we
justify things that we know for example
by looking at them
okay
and i thought oh this isn't going to be
an interesting talk because i'm just
kind of you know
just
mentioning a whole bunch of truisms
and it turns out it was described in the
q a as oh you're very provocative
shocking
and so i guess the answer is yeah i'm
kind of an extreme view but
um
you know as people sometimes say who end
up with extreme view i really didn't
plan to end up here
you know
and believe me i'll move to the center
if i can figure out how
and is it so
also let me lay some jargon on the
audience too you've already used the
word nominalism uh i'm only catching up
in the last couple years with what that
even means so the nominalist
aspect of your thought is a denial of
reality for a whole bunch of
abstractions that other people might
think are real is that safe to say
exactly the nominalist says
um there are no numbers there are no
mathematical objects they don't exist in
any sense at all there's only one sense
of exist according to me that's
important
uh there are no properties there are no
relations we talked about this and
there's a whole bunch of other things
that they don't exist although we talk
about them like corporations like
so yeah i'm uh i'm a
wide
ranging nominalist but this is key
right and this came up also in what we
were talking about certain kinds of
nominalists think if you're gonna deny
that something
exists
you can't say
you know uh there are blahs you can't
really even talk about them
i'm not that kind of nominalist i think
you can talk about them that's why i'm
telling that funny story about truth
right so a classic example would be
something like uh there are prime
numbers between 10 and 20. and exactly
you want to be able to say both there
are prime numbers between 10 and 20 and
there are no numbers
right and you can do it we do do it you
can say
uh there are
several let's say prime numbers between
let's not try to count them in real time
but that is not to say that
prime numbers exist right
and now what you're doing there is
you're doing a kind of contrast move
again it's linguistics here
you're now using the word exist
to
implicate
uh really exists and you're using you're
not using there is that way
right
and so there's a very kind of subtle
interplay in the language
and it's part of the reason why we have
distinct words like exist real and there
is
all of those words can be used at times
to
uh in a lightweight way we're not really
talking about what's real
but then other sometimes when we want to
indicate what's real
we use them contrastively
good and that's an illustration so your
kind of nominalist is going to be able
to is going to want to be able to
make statements that are true or false
uh have a truth value but don't refer to
anything in real in the world
that's right for example
sherlock holmes is a lot smarter than
mickey mouse right
you know or um uh sherlock holmes is
more famous than any detective
real or not
oh okay
i think that's true yeah can you think
of a real i bet you can't even think of
the name of a real detective let alone
a famous one
right you know i once said this i once
said this is a sad sociological fact
and i still believe it so i'm going to
keep repeating it
fictional objects fictional characters
are more famous than any real people
and i i i think that's something weird
about us that you know that that's true
so so it that yeah but it's an
interesting point because you're saying
that we can actually
compare
uh
fictional and non-fictional things real
and non-real things we do all the time
we do all the time yeah i can say
something like this imaginary woman i
dream of every night looks just like
and then i don't know bretta garbo
whatever
or or or somebody who's alive at the at
the moment
so so that's nominalism can is it worth
uh
helping out our audience or or torturing
them a little bit by talking about
quine's view of what is real i mean
famously maybe this is the most favorite
thing for philosophers to say about what
is real quine had this inscrutable
sentence about bound variables
yes
basically what that comes down to in
natural language what's happening here
and it's always important with 20th
century analytic philosophy is you've
always got to keep in mind
the
that they are thinking about one way or
another the importance of the invention
of logic
okay and i call it the invention of
logic at the hands of fraga
and really what it was the invention of
was the first artificial language
sophisticated artificial language
sufficient for doing all of mathematics
in all
okay
in a formalism okay so that was an
invention and they worry about this so
the bit about the bound variables has to
do with quine's favorite formalism
but let's just put the point in natural
language which he felt he could actually
because what he was doing is he was
transliterating statements from natural
language
into his favorite formalism
okay and the statement is simply that if
you have to say there are blas
then you are committed to the reality of
blas
that's called his criterion
again bells and whistles about first
order logic which i'm going to skip
sure but the point is if you can't get
out from saying there are blahs you're
committed to the the laws and it's
really that you have to be able to say
things about them not that you could say
things about them it's that you have to
so the the reason why kwine found
himself being a platonist as he called
it which means he was committed to
mathematical objects
was because he took physics seriously
and for much of his life that was the
only science he took seriously it was a
bit restrictive
but let's not worry about that okay the
point is he takes physics seriously well
unfortunately for him as a as a
philosopher ontologist if you're going
to take physics seriously then you got
to take mathematics seriously then you
got to take statements
there are statements where what follows
there are
are claims about numbers functions etc
hilbert spaces
conclusion you're committed to these
things they exist
so any project like mine which says
i'm going to look at your physical
theory and i'm going to try to factor
out the mathematics because you're not
committed to the mathematical objects
you're only committed to the physical
objects
that project for quine is off the table
right
because you said there are
we're done you're stuck
and you don't agree so what is your i
mean this is a pretty still a pretty
popular view as far as i can tell among
many philosophers but uh it's it's still
a very popular view it is the go-to view
it is one of the reasons that coin will
be on the philosophical map now and
forever yeah because this is kind of the
view where you have to start
my answer is twofold depending on
whether coin is going to take refuge in
natural language or whether he's going
to work in a formalism
if he's going to take refuge in natural
language i say natural language doesn't
work that way
you're just wrong
okay there are as many greek gods as
goddesses perfectly good statements true
no one's committed right
we have to understand when we introduce
commitment in natural language it turns
out to be subtle and again a matter of
linguistics yeah that makes sense if
right if on the other hand kwine says
never mind natural language that that
botched that mess that thing that
evolved horribly look at it look at it
oh i avert my eyes let's look at the
formalisms
then the response is
a formalism only commits you to what you
stipulate in the formulism does commits
you there's nothing about any
formalistic little object a quantify or
anything else that yells out
i'm committing
okay and that's true even when you take
that formalism and now i'm going to
throw more jargon out which hopefully
you won't demand i explain
you give that formalism an
interpretation
a semantic interpretation you don't it's
not just a formalism it means something
again
you have to build into the meaning
the commitments they don't just show up
so there's no argument here
and there's no argument that anyone has
that we have to read any of the
languages we use natural language or
formalisms mathematics etc in a way that
requires us by virtue of there are
followed by noun phrase
has to commit us
so for example uh a common thing that
philosophers will say is that
you've already alluded to this fact
science physics in particular uses math
all the time you you can't get you can't
state the standard model of particle
physics without using math in any way
that we know
therefore that involves there is
statements that's right right so i mean
i'm stating that what i take to be the
conventional philosopher's view which i
don't think either you or i share but
it's that since you are committed to
making use of those ideas those
mathematical ideas to be a good
physicist you have to believe in these
abstract entities as real
that's right
and i'm simply denying that yeah and and
and if i can try to rephrase your denial
it's that
no that's your denial i said you know
you can talk about these things and use
them and committing to their existence
is a separate independent step
exactly exactly and i claim that's
licensed
by how natural language actually works
how these words exist there is actually
work
and or it's licensed by
the options we have when we're using a
formalism and how we interpret it
so one thing to that that this raises as
a question that needs answering then is
why is mathematics so good why is it so
reliable if it's not
real
uh but there's it
it's objectively true but not real
should that worry us
um
i think yes it calls for an explanation
i have spilt much ink as they say
um although it hasn't been ink it's more
like
the kind of resources that bitcoin
chews up
right
in answering this question and i
actually think it's a case-by-case
answer i mean one of the things you can
do to make the question look far more
forbidding and frightening
is to say something like mathematics the
whole thing
is
reliable
in the sciences the whole thing but
that's not the right picture
the right picture is specific branches
of mathematics in specific branches of
the sciences and specific branches of
physics and then it becomes much more
manageable how to tell a story
okay
for example the vast majority of
20th century mathematics
has no applications whatsoever
it's it's wonderful stuff it's beautiful
stuff and it may have applications this
is by no means an argument for
trimming mathematics departments
okay
but you know
there are lots of stories the stories
about how you know
um riemann's um
developments in um
non-euclidean geometry took a bunch of
years before they found an application
lots of mathematics has no application
so you have to focus in on the stuff
that does
and then when it has applications
again you you don't want to be too
broadly
you know in your picture about this
often the applications are specific
and sometimes you end up telling a very
specific story based on the underlying
physical reality that tells you why that
mathematics works now here's a kind of
simple-minded example
i have a a chalkboard once upon a time
people did
and you you you draw geometrical objects
on the chalkboard and you notice that
euclidean geometry more or less works
for those figures yeah and if somebody
says why does it work there's no deep
mystery here although a lot of it is
going to end up involving physics that
we don't entirely understand right why
the chalk adheres the way it does to the
board i don't understand it yeah
right frictional effects we all know how
hard it is to make sense of them etc etc
nevertheless the story that will emerge
literally tells us why euclidean
geometry is going to be up to maybe very
high approximation the right mathematics
to
to use on those figures
now when you're dealing with a
fundamental physical science
let's say particle physics at a certain
stage here are the particles and here
are the brute facts about them and
notice we can now use a certain
algebraic
um a formulation maybe something
invented by hamilton
william hamilton in the in the 19th
century and we go yeah yeah yeah we can
use that and somebody says why does it
work
and now you're at
a brute level
we don't know why it works no more than
we know why the particles act the way
they do right
at a certain point a new theory may
emerge that's more fundamental oh i
don't know string theory
and then the string theory will have its
own distinctive geometry and in terms of
that we may be able to say here's why
this works up here
that's how it always goes
so i like it so again i'm going to try
to rephrase to make sure that i
understand uh people will say look at
all this math that is so useful in
physics clearly the math must be real it
must have some uh abstract
independence and therefore reality that
doesn't depend on the physical world but
you're saying well no it's not math as
such
that that has used it's certain pieces
of math and those pieces of math have
used because they're representing the
physical world what the what exists is
the physical world and we abstract a
little bit from that for our purposes
but that doesn't mean we need to
attribute reality to our abstractions
that's right um
and here's how i would put it even a
little slightly differently but really
it's what you just said i would say we
can use a certain branch of mathematics
uh and we can take certain terms of the
mathematics and yes we can have them
represent aspects of the physical world
okay
and
sometimes we can tell a story in terms
of more fundamental facts
why we can do that
and sometimes we can't
right okay
now you know there's nothing surprising
here really well one potentially
surprising thing or one of those things
which we need to decide whether it's
surprising or not is the existence of
the laws of physics themselves right so
we've been talking about math but there
is an ongoing debate about the the
status of the laws of physics there are
humans which would say laws of physics
just a convenient
way of summarizing what happens in the
world and there are anti-humans who i've
made fun of because they don't have a
person to attach their position to they
just
are anti-hume but uh they're gonna say
that the physical laws have some umph
have some separate existence and one of
the most casual but obvious arguments in
favor of that is
why would they keep working if they if
they didn't have some separate existence
should we be surprised that the laws of
physics work just as well today as they
did yesterday if all they are is a
summary of of the world doing its thing
well
again my response and it may not satisfy
everybody
is what's in back of this issue is a
certain picture that we have of
how we explain things
and sometimes we have this real belief
it gets more formalized in philosophy
but i think it's operative
uh all over the place
that
you know everything can be explained or
should be explainable
and we don't like the idea that
sometimes something is brute and all i
mean by brood is explanatory brute right
there it is
there's nothing that tells me
and i don't see any kind of
philosophical argument or any other kind
of argument for that matter that's gonna
establish the fact that
if if i can write down a certain
generalization about how the world works
that
there has to be an explanation for why
that generalization
works i'm like
why
maybe there is
but but notice if there is it's going to
be in terms of something else
right
that also isn't going to be that that
itself might not be explainable
there's nothing that tells me
that
everything is either explainable or
self-explainable here we're like
bordering on you know theological
notions you know well no god but
you know
it's self-explainable i don't know what
that means right what i do know is that
if you have a generalization you may be
able to explain it in terms of something
else other generalizations
or you may not
and if you're not you're not
period end nothing more to say be humble
i'm very much in favor of being humble i
like that and again you're expressing
exactly what i want my view to be but i
i will confess
to a sliver of
uh sympathy for the idea that i'd be
happier
if there was some principled reason why
i should expect the laws of physics to
be just as good tomorrow as they were
yesterday i i think that
it's a feature it's like you say it's a
way of talking about the world that that
has been working so far the zeroth order
thing is to expect it to keep working uh
but i get why people want more than that
even though i don't think it exists
yeah i almost feel
that this is a hankering yeah
for
as i would put it solving the problem of
induction
how are those related yeah
life has been good so far
can't we get a guarantee here right and
i'd like to say yeah i understand why
you want a guarantee you know
but but no you can't
period we're done
okay i mean that's what i would say to
that i get it i it again i'm very
sympathetic there let me yeah
tough love right yeah exactly you know
no one ever promised you a rose garden
uh
so let me let let's just uh come close
to finishing up here by pushing on what
i've heard from my philosopher friends
uh as
their best arguments in favor of
platonism in favor of some attributing
some reality to mathematical entities
one of them goes back to what you
already alluded to the existence of
these non-standard models of arithmetic
so when you have a formal system
mathematical system that is as powerful
as arithmetic uh we know
i'm not going to get this right because
i'm very terrible at mathematical logic
but uh
we we certainly know that you can't
prove that they're consistent internally
right
girdle prove that we also know that uh
there will be statements you can
formulate in the language of that system
uh which are
either unprovable
or the system is inconsistent right
and somehow it follows that there are
these inevitably multiple models from
the same set of axioms so this is a very
long-winded way of saying
one might have thought because i know
because i did used to think this that
matt all of math was kind of like
geometry right geometry you have the
parallel postulate you can have
different versions of it and you get
different geometries and so you just say
you pick different axioms and what math
is about is figuring out what follows
from the axioms but i've i've been
corrected in that because uh when you're
when your axioms are as powerful enough
to include arithmetic
what follows from the axioms is not the
whole story because of these different
models so
i think i followed that much but then
there's this extra leap that comes at
the end
therefore the fact that one plus one
equals two
needs some extra truth over and above
just sticking with some axioms
well the the actual picture is something
like this what's happening is right i
mean you're right the idea is though
it's not the whole story
that means there are more truths
that are not being captured by the axiom
system so in some sense
syntactic
deducibility
is transcended by truth
in what's happening okay
what in what i think
that's roughly the idea
there's more to say
that we can't get access to
if the system is consistent right unless
we supplement the axioms now that's to
me is the key phrase
so what's going on here is it's
incompleteness
yeah an axiom system
worth its salt
least arithmetic
is incomplete
which means
all that incompleteness is is that there
are statements p
where you cannot show p and you cannot
show not p not with those axioms
you can find other axioms that more
powerfully
will dictate p or not p
now there's another piece to the puzzle
we can introduce a formal notion of
truth
okay
uh um
you know using the what are called the
tarsky biconditionals a set of them
things like that as to characterize it
we can now supplement the axiom system
in a certain way by introducing that
notion into it
and we will get
new results
that we couldn't show otherwise
it's still incomplete but it's strictly
bigger than what we had before
but it will never be complete you're
never going to add enough to make it
complete
not if you're going to write down a set
of axioms that you can actually survey
that are recursively innumerable no yeah
that's the key that's the key point
okay now what does this show does this
show that there are truths out there
that we don't have access to
was subject to the interpretation of how
we're reading the truth predicate we
just introduced yes
otherwise no
so my response is
i've just said it yeah yeah yeah rig it
a certain way interpret that predicate a
certain way
and sure
there are truths that you cannot show
otherwise the only result is it's
incomplete
but you're not gonna let them go from
there are truths you can not show to
therefore there must be abstractly real
things out there
i'm actually not even going to let them
go to their truths you cannot show oh i
thought you just did let them go there
sorry
yeah i don't want to do that i want to
say there are statements neither of
which you can show p or not p
okay it's an additional move to say well
one of those p or not p is true
at that point
you have a substantial notion of a
standard model that you're bringing to
bear
or you're interpreting the predicate
that you introduced in a very specific
way
that's how you get
truths otherwise you don't get it so
what i'm claiming here is that
yeah there's still a stipulation going
on that's how you do this
otherwise it's just an axiom system and
a nice bigger axiom system
well is it also
useful to note and i honestly don't know
the answer to this one um that these
statements
such that
you can prove neither p nor not p in
your
system of arithmetic these are pretty
way out statements none of these
statements are really relevant to doing
physics or anything like that and
therefore can you just take the attitude
who cares
not necessarily because um
the statements that we've managed to
show
that are this sort
you're right are pretty far out they end
up you know they're established by very
uh technical sophisticated means and
they don't have a nice or obvious
mathematical content
uh but there are some that look closer
to having a nice mathematical content
and there's nothing that's stopping this
right okay
okay
so incompleteness
you can't you cannot say we do not know
as far as i can tell oh yeah the the
statements that can't be shown by a nice
in a nice axiom system like piano
arithmetic are ones you don't care about
anyway
that that we cannot show not not there
okay okay
maybe we'll never get there no we'll
never be there never get there because i
actually think there probably are some
we can use
that'd be interesting it'd be
interesting to see such a such a thing
well one of the ways that there are one
of the ways to get there
is to introduce new and strange
mathematical concepts
this is happening the most in set theory
contemporary set theory
and when you introduce those that may be
a way of getting a grip on
a genuine supplementation of your
previous mathematics
that has
content that you really can see
is going to have uh
an effect right
for example on the continuum on on the
real number system and therefore in
principle at least on your physics in
principle i'm i'm not so sure about that
but we don't know like you said we don't
know so we don't know we don't know
that's why i said in principle isn't it
in principle a nice cautious phrase it
really is
i was hoping it was
so i was trying to be cautious here
let me let me phrase sort of what might
be another version of the same point but
in in
different words and this comes from
justin clark doan who is a uh
philosopher who i had on the podcast
earlier to talk about mathematics and
morality and
he
emphasizes the bit about consistency in
these axiomatic systems um
the the
the postulates of arithmetic piano
arithmetic etc have implications for the
consistency of the theory itself right
like you can't prove it within the
system and so he he would argue that if
you think
that there's an objective claim
that arithmetic is consistent
in other words that you can not imagine
building a touring machine that would
eventually prove zero equals one
then you must think that these
arithmetic claims are objectively true
independent in a way that doesn't just
come down to the axioms
so that's what that's his argument for
needing something else other than just
saying well there's different axioms and
they're all equally good for describing
different things
i'm going to disagree okay i'm going to
say look the the interesting notion
ultimately he's he's building into his
notion of consistency a semantic
component
i'm thinking consistency just means
syntactic consistency which means yes
turing machine you get zero equals one
at the end that's syntactic
inconsistency
the sad fact is we never get to show
that
we don't
if
you know basically as long as you've
been
churning out results as long as you
haven't shown an inconsistency as far as
you know there isn't one but that's not
there's no decision procedure here
and if you embed it in a bigger system
and prove with respect to the bigger
system that it's consistent
well you've essentially spun your wheels
because
you don't know that the bigger system is
consistent
right and again i mean syntactically
deriving
some suitable contradiction in the
bigger system
so to me that's it there's nothing more
to the notion of consistency than that
and there's nothing more to say here to
cheer ourselves up
there's a fact of the matter and the
fact of the matter is whether you can
derive zero equals one and piano
arithmetic
but this is a fact that we cannot this
is a syntactic fact but we can't show it
well
it's tricky because if we built a turing
machine that that did prove it then we
would have shown it
oh absolutely absolutely that's how
um that's how showing something is
consistent works by the way
you build a model but then of course
that's relative to the stronger
um system you're in so so your attitude
is that we should just be happy not
being sure that arithmetic is consistent
that's right we should just accept that
and not worry about it because
again
uh life doesn't give us anything else
okay
harsh lessons we're getting here from
you jody this is you know
you have to bite a lot of bullets
[Laughter]
but i think these are bullets that you
know
i don't know we're stuck with yeah i
agree
okay so then the final question is um
you know we talked about what is real
what is what is not real we focused on
things like tables and chairs laws of
physics numbers
and axioms
what about uh good and evil or or
beautiful and ugly uh are there
implications for your way of thinking
for moral realism aesthetic realism
other kinds of realisms i mean
i'm gonna guess that since you don't
think numbers are real you probably
don't think that moral morals are real
either
well in one sense i certainly don't um i
don't think there's any sort of entities
or commitments or anything like that
going on
i'm um i guess i haven't written about
this so you know i i always have to be
careful because i end up writing things
that are a little different from what i
sometimes anticipate
um but my view is i'm a kind of
naturalist about this
okay
and broadly speaking when i think about
morality i think about
we have our evolution to uh
find certain things repulsive or
appealing
and
our practice of making agreements with
one another
and that's kind of how i see this
working
okay
and i mean there are people thinking
well if we evolved differently
uh
in a more reptilian way to be insulting
to the reptiles
we we might
then would that mean it was perfectly
okay to eat each other in certain under
certain circumstances
or or something like that do horrific
things
and
um
if we were those reptiles i think the
answer would probably be yes
but we're not we're not those guys
okay i'm on board with that too uh
i guess
i will have one final question which is
it would be a shame to let people go
without noting that
uh in addition to writing a whole bunch
of books about what exists and what
doesn't exist you also write fiction and
poetry um so i'll just advertise that
but also
is there a connection that is either
explicit or implicit between your poetry
and your philosophy is is this something
that uh people should be more aware of
i don't think so okay although there are
friends of mine who disagree
some of the
some of the poems
are infused with philosophical themes
and and maybe in some of my
philosophical writing i wax a little
more poetic than i should
um but
at the end of the day i'm a kind of
wordsmith that's what i do i work with
language and i care about language and i
deal with all aspects of it and that
includes the creative aspects as well as
the
you know
aspects of how we use language to
understand the world
and um i'm equally committed to all
those projects
but that doesn't mean that they need
have much overlap i mean sometimes i use
this analogy imagine someone who's a
really good swimmer and a good
basketball player they use their arms
in both cases they just don't quite use
them the same way
i think it's perfectly fair and i think
you've given us some good words to think
about again with the caveat that words
that we say here extemporaneously are
not always as careful as the words we
would write down after after careful
thought but uh i think you're giving us
a lot to think about so jody zuni thanks
so much for being on the mindscape
podcast
thank you
[Music]
you